do you feel like do you get into the
conspiracy aspect of like [ __ ] like
not even just covert but just in general
do you like are you like i think it's
something else be honest
i don't think this is like i feel like
this is all like there's something else
going on
like what though i have no idea we never
know what's like
they always do some [ __ ] then some other
[ __ ] happen like oh you know what i mean
because if you think about it this is my
opinion when all the protesting was
going on
god blessed the dead yeah um george
floyd when all that happened and
everybody was protesting nobody did you
didn't see
for at least a month straight i never
even heard the word and there was people
groups of people everywhere protesting
police was
packed 200 cops everywhere like so then
you know that dies that died down and
then and then they saying all these
cities cases that went up
you know what i mean they're still
protesting it's just on the news
the hype around it didn't die down
unless it's some wild violent crazy
like portland that's on the news because
in portland this [ __ ] is crazy it's
going down like anywhere it's going down
there's nothing going to show you that
you're in seattle like seattle they had
that little area did you like
in seattle they had like a little the
protesters
my little brother live out there yeah
there was this [ __ ] called the chad zone
and they shut it off from police like a
whole area of capitol hill
and it was like you couldn't go in and
out unless
it was wild it's going down they said
they you know that that flame
has been set so it's hard but if it
ain't going if it ain't like
something they don't want you to feel
like they need this show they ain't
gonna show you
well they should they just admitted the
uh pentagon just admitted that ufos are
real
it was in washington time this week yeah
i knew i hadn't seen an alien or two in
my [ __ ] life
i mean obviously outside of custies you
know what i'm saying
i know how to say that there's some [ __ ]
like from men in black remember that
[ __ ]
oh yeah alien [ __ ] yeah they
admitted to aliens and all that [ __ ]
have you ever
uh they probably know him i know you you
the last time we talked to you probably
call them and all that oh yeah
uh i think they got aliens at work
definitely on probably in contact with a
few of the billions
i wouldn't put that past none of that
government [ __ ] no they got aliens to
work bro i'm telling you they got
[ __ ] that work for the
government
area what do you think area 51 is these
[ __ ] live on base bruh
crazy it's i'm telling you yo we gonna
see that they're just preparing us
slowly i think if trump loses before he
loses
he's just gonna [ __ ] everyone's life up
and be like guess what
aliens are real i'm out you gonna tell
him to pop out
y'all can pull up now yeah pull up [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i lost
pull up i lost there's gonna be a bunch
of aliens coming through this [ __ ]